at this final General Affairs Council to
be held during the Netherlands
presidency there were obviously a number
of important items on the agenda such as
the EU priorities for 2017 and further
improving the EU by means of better
regulation and Gaeta transparency of
course as you all know the biggest focus
today was on the decision of the British
people to leave the European Union
reaction for most of the members was
these three hours i would say regret
respect and also resolve what we read
not right now is a european union that
answers the security concerns of our
citizens that creates more jobs and more
prosperity it's now up to the UK
government to trigger article 50 but
it's clear that the large majority of
member states want as soon as possible
to start negotiations in this contract
it's important to go back to the order
of the day and focus on other important
item on today's agenda the preparation
for the European Council so in any case
we have a very full agenda to the agenda
migration stock taking jobs girls in
investment and external relations today
we embarked on what will become a new
tradition intended to make more
effective the use of this council the
General Affairs Council the aim is also
to improve the quality of European
Council conclusions and to and enhance
compliance I spoke this president asked
about this so that we can go in a much
more effective cycle of preparation of
the European Council which we did
intensively today but also the
implementation part but if we want to
improve Europe and we want to and that
we have a strategic agenda that we don't
have all the law making machinery but we
prioritize now in the into institutional
agreement we made sure that the
programming is now listen to by the
Commission and they listen first also to
the council so we add our input today
the second is on transparency now
transparency is an issue that you can
endlessly discuss that will not solve
all the issues of citizens of
participation but it's a condition for
that and again I've tried today to make
sure that on the issue of the trial log
process the common database for the EU
institutions the register for delegated
acts we make progress
you